last week I announced that my book
Howard Stern comes again was the
best-selling non-fiction book of 2019 on
Apple right and salan Richard became in
totally nude and had a congratulatory
banner tied to their penises one of the
highlights of my year was not only
releasing the book but some of the ways
we actually promoted the book we had a
gospel choir sing about my boss oh
that's right the first day the whole
floor was shaking most of the really
funny stuff was richard and sal doing
stuff like right like richard and honor
of the book being released at a
champagne toast and we poured champagne
in his [ __ ] and its rectum let's hear
the champagne go in all right be careful
he can get drunk he knows whole and then
it just slowly goes in like when you and
also I want to thank high-pitch Eric who
did the way off the other day you know
what I remembered when I was thinking
about all the book promotion we did what
remember when Benji ended up jerkin off
Sal and Richard bike like yay him up a
little bit we were having callers guest
the combined length of Richard and Sal's
penises they were five inches combined
combined so then Benji came up with the
idea to jerk both of them all at the
same time to see who would get hard
first let's read this is there
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
what really surprised me listening back
was how excited Benji got he was in
shock he screamed it was quite
remarkable so thank you for all of that
right Robin that's right